[Music]
even my
kids everybody happy Thursday everyone
ah you look tantalizing
you know I make fun of the view a lot
but that's only because they keep
talking
those hands are always clucking they get
to say stupid stuff for an hour every
day and then I get to say stupid stuff
for an hour every day except on purpose
but every now and then one of those ding
bats inadvertently says something that
reveals modern liberal thoughts so
perfectly it deserves further study you
know like a weird serpent that washed up
on the beach and you want to poke it
with a stick
take the covid lockdowns remember all
the small businesses that went under all
the children scarred psychologically and
emotionally because they couldn't
socialize with each other it broke up
marriages and ruined what I had with
Taylor Swift
well never mind all that stuff because
covet also taught Sunny hoston how to
get her groceries delivered yeah I know
amazing but that means it's time for
living your life and you're feeling low
you don't know what is true
so you quick flip through the channels
to watch sunny on The View foreign
[Music]
with lots of nonsense to Proclaim
to show where people know the hustle
stupid
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
nicely done Gene
you are hired for one more day
so Sonny I bet you haven't been in a
supermarket since coveted for about
three years
I haven't been in a supermarket
for about three years that's when I
discovered instacart and I I give them a
big tip because they don't always pay
their their people well and it's it's so
that's been an issue I think for the
company but man you can get toiletries
you can get fire logs you know those big
Bounty towels you don't want carrots
from Costco somebody else
fire logs
she had to tell the audience that she
tips big because even she knows she
sounds insufferable hey but at least I
tip
this Dame probably virtue signals on the
toilet
but that's not the point here well
everybody else was trying to figure out
how to survive as the government told us
that breathing in public could kill us
Sonny was lulling around in her big
house clicking on pictures of arugula
while mixing Cocoa Puffs into a haagadas
oh the oppression I wonder if she wiped
down the groceries herself or had her
maid do it
she tips her too
sure lots of people start getting their
groceries delivered during covid because
we were told it would help save the
world from the deadly virus that
suddenly appeared for no apparent reason
leaked by no particular world government
We're All in This Together We're All in
This Together remember just like
Jonestown
but unlike this chick we didn't think it
was the best thing that could have
happened to us although it did get Joy
Behar to wear a mask
right
[Applause]
before you make me sick it's funny her
her being named Joy is like me being
named ugly
foreign
but we didn't breathe a sigh relief that
we'd never have to set foot in a grocery
store again I love grocery stores I
treat them like strip clubs I'll spend
hours in the cookie aisle staring at the
Keebler elves until I'm aroused then
I'll stick a fiber in the bra the old
lady handing out free samples
I'm only kicked out I'm only kicked out
when security thinks my jean shorts are
too small
they can never be too small
but most people went back to the grocery
stores when the emergency was over we
went back to normal true I went back to
not washing my hands and instead happily
sneezing on the elderly
but if you work on The View or anywhere
else in the liberal media you're
insulated from the world just like
blubber insulates them from the cold
I give those poor people a big tip for
screwing around Gathering food for me
and Hauling it to my Mansion yeah thanks
for the 20 bucks lady that's good for
two to three gallons of gas so I can get
back home to my kids who are having
bologna sandwiches for the ninth night
in a row for dinner and urinal cakes for
dessert
oh yeah
you know when the rest of us criticized
the lockdown's lingering effects people
like Sunny just wave it away because it
hasn't affected them at all for her it
was one giant excuse to sit at home and
dip Eskimo pies into alfredo sauce
she doesn't care because she doesn't
have to it's a class thing and it's why
she plays the race card so often so you
don't notice it's a class thing her life
stinks of classism crime is on the rise
just higher private security illegals
are flooding into the country don't live
near the border covid just stay home
forever let the peons take the risk for
me schools suck hey more idiots to watch
The View
lady is more out of touch than Janet
yellen's Barber
[Applause]
it's a barber
it's the old Howard Stern rant you
idiots who need Freedom are killing
people why don't you just sit home like
me in my Hamptons compound and work from
home again let the peons take all the
risks my God how the mighty fart man has
fallen
these Elites are so isolated they've
forgotten that most Americans don't get
paid to sit in a comfy chair
pontificating about everything all day
nope some of us are cameramen whose
names I don't know
[Laughter]
but maybe one day when we finally strip
away this phony race war it will finally
expose this Elite mentality and we'll
find out Sunny is just like Marie
Antoinette except she says let me eat
cake
[Applause]
sign at an ant farm co-host of America's
Newsroom and the five day to Burrito
he's responsible for more callers than
Izod former an NYPD inspector Paul
Morrow
[Applause]
he may be part titanium but he's
strongest in his Cranium retired Marine
Corps bomb technician Johnny Joey Joe
and finally she's like the Dead Sea
Scrolls hard to read and covered in dust
boxes contributor captive
foreign
yes yes and I'm glad you kept the same
clothes on that you wore on the five
yeah well it's been a long day it has
been a long day weren't we the only show
I would say this show the five we're the
only shows that bucked this sentiment we
were the ones saying like we're on TV we
can't tell people how to live their
lives absolutely and we were worried I
was I specifically remember being
worried about the taxicab drivers
because they a lot of people in America
actually live paycheck to paycheck but
if you're if you own a cab and you're
not getting any customers that means you
are not able to take care of your family
and that was a really big deal also for
sunny if you are a person that talks
about how big of a Tipper you are yes
the chances of you actually not being
that great a Tipper are really high
that's the Jesse Waters thing right it
always talks about his tipping yes
Jesse's honest he's not a great Tipper
okay he's honest about it and I would
imagine that the people feel clean up
her instacart don't think she's the
greatest Tipper yeah and yeah and then
she she bashes the company like they
don't pay their workers right you know
that's like so she's still she's still
like one of them you know she's one of
them oh yeah but but I give him extra
money she's so sweet that's Sunny uh
Paul do you catch the view very often is
it on your uh DVR but it's the view into
what domestic hell what exactly is it a
view into and who came up with the names
if you think about it sunny Joy I
actually think at some point here we may
all be getting trolled because this is
clearly such BS are we really supposed
to believe that first of all what does
she do she researched the company to see
what they pay their people she went on
the internet and pulled their tax
returns somehow or whether I'm skeptical
yeah and any idea that Joy Behar is so
uh interested in going out in the
supermarkets and you know mixing with
people getting your opinions you know I
want to go with a shop of eggs I just
want to hear from you know Trump Nation
yeah okay right you know what she says
when she talks to conservatives in
supermarkets
where's your manager yes
yes because that's who she's talking
that's what they're hearing right yeah I
want to talk to your super this coupon
is good
[Music]
it's sad that this 12 pack of pastries
was on sale I know it says 19.99 but I'm
telling you it's still good yes it
smells good you know who I am yes
exactly she tries to eat all the food
before they put it on the scale and by
the way that that mental image of you in
the short shorts senior dial yeah thanks
for that yeah it doesn't have to be
mental talk to me later
Joey uh yeah I don't know he looks we're
good man this is listen this is what
happened when you take men out of
serious conversation
sexist would say yes nicely done yeah
you know I've learned from the best but
but you know that's why I'm outnumbered
we always have one lucky biological
cisgender male sitting right in the
middle just to keep things where they
need to be yeah when you when you let
those four or five women have it those
four or five women have at it they just
go places that make no sense whatsoever
and listen how much are you supposed to
pay somebody that pulls things off of
shelves and puts them in a cart for you
I'm just curious like what is paying
them well and what is paying them badly
I mean I just paid a guy 25 an hour to
come help me pick things up and move
them but at least like we were being
productive yeah you know like you know
what are you supposed to pay somebody to
grocery shop for you I mean you can't
just hand them your dignity which is
what you should do so what can you pay
them I have to say that I have uh I do
use uh I I use it's not instacart but
once in a while I will send somebody to
a 7-Eleven are you buy on your firewood
that way no it's 11 o'clock and I got
Munchies if this shirt says nothing else
it says I chopped my own wood yeah I
mean come on do you think she's a closet
arsonist because she said that she's
been doing she's buying fire logs and
paper towels it's she does have some
antifa Vibe yeah I think she's part of
antifa it's the blender I think we
I think we uh broke some news here so
Kat let's talk about the class issue
here I think and I said this earlier and
in my monologue that I believe that she
is she's like a perfect classist she is
a snob she's an elitist but she hides
behind the race card so you can't come
at her she's got all the breaks she's
got all the money she obviously like
wants the peons to take the risks that
she doesn't have to all right yeah
um okay look uh I don't think that part
of it was that bad I don't think like I
don't want to sound like a huge one
percenter here but I don't think that
instacart is just like a millionaire
thing right uh not everybody who uses
instacart has the kind of money that she
has my main issue with this segment was
how mind-numbingly boring it was
they were talking about their grocery
preferences I watched the whole thing
for quite an extended period of time
Sunny was like I I hate the store
fiery hot take there and she then she's
like yeah I like instacart but don't
worry I tip the pores but you know Joy
you actually don't like instacart and
you do like the store and then Joy is
like yeah I do I like to go to the store
I like to walk around and see what's at
the store what I do want what I don't
want maybe I want tuna fish and I just
want to hit myself in the face so I can
feel something you know it's like so
boring and
I'm not so bothered by the fact that
like oh she's so rich she uses instacart
I think she's oppressed I'm bothered by
the fact that she got rich having
conversations that are that boring yeah
hey uh
you know you keep applauding her she's
going to continue to use that foul
length
try
terrible hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else